dr van france we said earlier that a man
with the mother complex
fantasizes on an ideal woman who will
fulfill his fantasies
gratify all his infantile desires
he wants a girl just like the girl that
married year old dad
how does that mother complex affect his
personal relationships with a woman
when a man has a mother complex he's
generally a split
animal namely on one side his feminine
side
is he worships the feminine image too
much it's a kind of virgin mary
or feminine holy ghost figure the pure
wonderful woman so to speak
and the other is the prostitute whom
with whom he has sex but whom he
thoroughly despises that
that this kind of split in the animal
between
the virgin mary and the prostitute
is typical for for the mother complex
and such men then if if they have to
approach a woman they don't know how to
do it because the one here they admire
too much she's too
pure you can't stretch out your hand and
touch her
and the other is is easily
conquered but no partner really
just something to have sex with and such
men have
also in their own way trouble to relate
to women
because of that split animal situation
is promiscuity in a male connected with
this split
i think the promiscuity has to do with
something else it's simply that the
conventional christian barriers have
been pulled down and
the young generation now is
experimenting
with sex all over the place and
you you meet among those men and young
women who are promiscuous all sorts of
constellations mother complex father
conflicts all sorts of
it's a more general factor this
experimenting nowadays because the
christian barriers against sex have been
pulled down
and but then in the individual case
such a man would for instance date
a a girl who has a huge father complex
and is therefore
unapproachable or rapunzel who is
unapproachable in a tower
and always hesitate to go closer to her
i would even try to go to bed with her
and not succeed
and he would still be attached to that
girl and have
cheap sexual affairs on the side on the
other side
which do not satisfy him
that would be the situation in such a
man